stargate sg-1 the highs glows and my
favorite episode from the whole series
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so children of the gods was the first
double episode and the tone of the
episode is very much similar to the
movies and this was done very much on
purpose brad wright and robert cooper
really wanted to create an episode that
bridged between the two
now they already had big plans for how
the series was going to go in fact part
of richard dean anderson's contract was
very clear on how his character would be
developed
but
in the first two episodes we don't
really see a great deal of that mainly
because they are trying to link it to
the movie they want this to be an
expansion of the original film to the
point where they actually contacted
roland emmerich and dean devlin to try
to get their input and some notes from
where they hoped they thought that maybe
the tv show should go roland emerick and
dean devlin have wanted nothing to do
with this tv series they thought it was
a bit of an
abomination they were still hoping to
make a sequel to the stargate movie
but so they had nothing to do with it
but brad wright and cooper really still
wanted to create this
expansion from the movie so hence the
tone of the original double episodes
now unfortunately or so showcase who had
to the tv show at the time and i got to
say for them it was their biggest
premiere ever
um they wanted this show to be a bit
more grown up they wanted adult action
and unfortunately that's why we got the
boobs see
that was forced on brad wright and
robert cooper but as soon as the show
then went over to sci-fi um the whole
first two episodes was re-edited
re-clipped um some new special effects
are added as well because by the time
they got to do that they didn't have to
keep reusing that glider shot from the
original movie that they nicked
then they were actually able to beef up
the and improve the special effects
slightly
um
i should say that as well isn't it funny
how um all of these alien worlds look
like um quarries in canada or woodland
in canada but yeah
the budget wasn't amazing for the first
two series i gotta admit um i gotta be
honest with you i didn't really watch
stargate when it first came out i loved
the movie i watched the first couple of
episodes of the series and i thought no
i don't really like it
but i came back to it about halfway
through and then i hit me hard in series
two i'm gonna do a video on that shortly
spoiler it's the best series it's
amazing but one or two episodes from
stargate did initially put me off a big
thing for the new series is to create
like i said a foundation to then build
upon a foundation that they then built
and made this franchise what it was
and they did a brilliant thing and they
did a brilliant job with that but the
two big areas they have to do in this
first few episodes is they have to start
expanding the universe make it much
bigger than the movie because obviously
a two-hour movie then needs to stretch
into
22-24 episodes per series i have to
expand the universe and they did that
really quickly
but you also have to develop the
characters now there was a couple of
episodes that did that beautifully and a
couple of episodes
that didn't
telk
is a perfect example of this the episode
bloodlines introduced the teal casa
family now i also that never really made
sense he apparently didn't tell the
tower this because he thought they might
think his loyalties were split and yeah
but also from
just a logical point of view it makes no
sense why wouldn't he at any point take
his family out of that situation and put
them on earth where it's safe
it makes no sense he supposedly loves
his wife and daughter and sorry his son
so much
that um he wanted to protect them for
anything else and that he was doing this
for them in lots of ways
but then he doesn't actually protect
them
he was self-helping the sgc
they could have relocated his family
really easily and really safely but they
don't make no sense that this episode is
a bit of a doubter for me
you've also got the episode emancipation
with sam carter where um they go to a
world that is basically the inhabitants
like the mongols of british history of
british history and like the mongols of
ancient history
and they still have a very similar um
culture and in that culture women are
treated as a commodity sam is taken and
sold but then she beats up one of the
chieftains and they decide to change
thousands of years of their culture and
they basically see the light that women
are actually equals and the culture
changes
now this is a little bit of this episode
is a little bit of an expansion from
children of gods where we see sam carter
in the first time and very much being
defensive about herself being a woman
she's saying that she's had so many
hours flight time over the gulf and
she's she's you know this genius she's
done so much work she macgyvered the
stargate and all these sort of things
but then she feels very defensive she's
a bit of a feminist
this is an expansion of that
um and she obviously beats up the
chieftain achieved that
it's it's character
development though that they don't then
carry on this militant feminist or
storyline which is actually pretty good
i mean you know it's really mirrors the
the fight of women in the military and
in any of our
public services really but it wasn't
really necessary it wasn't a big thing
of sam's character later on when i talk
about my favorite episode of the series
i'll talk a little bit more about sam's
character development and when it really
started but that's later in the video
but going back to teal an episode that
really does develop his character is the
episode torai now in that episode the
sg-1 returned to a planet where teal
could been previously he'd been there on
the orders of apophis to take slaves
the people see him
realize what he is and what he had done
to them and they basically imprisoned
him and tealk won't fight back
o'neil repeatedly says we can just force
you we can get a rescue mission and we
will take you and t ilk says no
this is my punishment this is why he is
here
the guilt that he feels what he had done
on the orders of apophis carry him
through the entire series we see that
right through to the end of the series
right through to series 10.
it is his motivation it is why he's
doing it he's why he is fighting with
the towery that one episode
is how we see teal for the rest of the
series and it is an excellent episode
that really sets the tone for the entire
character
and the entire character's arc of him
looking for redemption
but knowing he's never going to find it
a couple of episodes then go on to
expand the universe for example we see
the eunice for the first time the goal
walls first hosts in the episode thor's
hammer an episode that also hints on the
existence of the asgard but only very
lightly hints on it
obviously at the start of the series the
children the gods we only know about the
gold and we assumed the gold built the
stargate system
we now started to realize through
episodes like thor's hammer though
actually that there are other races out
there
that there are other species and that
perhaps they didn't build the stargates
after all
in the episode the knox we meet the knox
one of those original four big species
a very technologically advanced species
that initially the sgc think they need
to protect
that they see them as almost childlike
um in tune with nature but then they
really very quickly realize that
actually this is a far more advanced
species and that actually instead of us
protecting them maybe they should be
protecting and teaching us
this was a really big episode that
really again gave us a hint of where the
sg-1 program and the where this series
and the wider universe was going to go
over 10 series
in the episode the torture of tantalus
we see that very specifically
it's a bit of a flashback episode where
we see that actually when the stargate
was initially discovered decades earlier
scientists had played with it and one
scientist dr littlefield had actually
gone through the gate now by this point
we already had the big list of stargate
addresses
but none of them seemed to work sam
carter needed to figure out that
actually over time the stars had moved
so that the addresses needed to be
adjusted to make up for that spatial
movement
stars literally are flying away from
each other at all times so the addresses
didn't work anymore the postcodes
changed
now they didn't know that decades
earlier and they basically stumbled
across this address by accident and
littlefield had gone through found
himself in this castle that was but the
fact that the address that they had gone
to that littlefield had traveled to
didn't actually appear on the cartouche
on the um tablet at abdos where they'd
got all of their stargate addresses from
led the sg1 team to realize and added
proof to the fact
that the gates weren't actually built by
the gold
they were able to get the address and
through sam with a bit of calculations
were able to reopen the gate and they
were able to go and get little feel back
during this time little phil showed
daniel a special room and in that room
atomic signatures in etobic mathematics
was projected on the ceilings and they
realized that this atomic mathematics
was a universal language that could be
used by anyone
and then he's found four distinct
languages this is the four most
important races in the universe at the
time
back to the time of the ancients the
asgard the knox and so on
all the way through the series when we
first meet the asgard they talk about
humanity one day stepping up to become
the fifth race
now this is something that i think we
stepped up to during the sg-1 and then
atlantis series but something that if i
see stargate return
something that maybe we could see a
little bit more
can we see humanity honestly step up to
become
the fifth race
so before i tell you my favorite episode
of the whole series i'm just going to
give you a couple of little honorary
mentions tin man is a very funny episode
um and the sgc turned up at a race he
basically makes him into robots we see a
lovely little character development and
really the humor of o'neill come through
in that episode as well and i also love
the follow-up episode in a later series
where those robot sg-1 team reappear
it's a great episode very very funny
politics is also a brilliant episode in
the final three episodes following there
but the grace of god and then the final
episode within the serpent's grasp sits
this episode politics now one of the
things i love most about stargate is the
fact that it's based on some sort of
reality it's not star trek it's not
science fiction in the future it could
really be happening now
in the politics episode even though
daniel
knows that apophis is coming and he is
about to destroy the sgc and the entire
planet
and enslave humanity once again
politics gets involved and senator
kingsey appears and he wants to shut the
sgc down he believes there is this
massive danger and he keeps talking
about cost as well and things like this
but he wants to shut it down
the thing i love about this episode so
much is is do we know that sort of thing
would happen we know people on the hill
would try and get involved and would try
and mess with people that they're just
trying to do what they need to get done
in the military we're trying to save
lives and
the politicians keep getting involved
and i don't know it just brought in the
best and the worst of humanity and i
really love that about this show and
it's one of the things i love about the
show so much
the last three episodes in the first
episode of season two though really
should be watched over and over again if
you're a gator and i'm sure have been um
it's the brilliant part of thing it it
creates attention and a cliffhanger
episode at the end of um in the
serpent's grasp it's not really been
done in many times in science fiction
i can't think of many
other than maybe the best of both worlds
the next generation that had a
cliffhanger episode that had such an
impact on me
as these three four episodes did
um but i would actually argue that sg-1
in the first series of episode 2 had a
better conclusion to this little group
of episodes
than
star trek best of both worlds episode 2
ever was
but my favorite episode from stargate
sg1 series 1
is solitudes
i love that whole episode so um the sg-1
team they're coming through the gate
they're under fire
staff weapon fire is hitting the gate
um teal and daniel go through
and then are thrown out the other side
into the sgc but sam and o'neal who are
just behind them don't appear
we then flash to an icy cave a gate
opens and simon o'neill come flying
through o'neill has broken his leg
sound then has to look after him um she
at one point climbs up to the um surface
to find out that there isn't enough
frozen wasteland she goes oh my god
we're on a frozen wasteland planet
there's nothing here
eventually daniel realizes that actually
they are on earth they're in antarctica
and there's a second gate a second gate
that becomes really really important
later on in the stargate sg1 series
but the thing i love about this episode
so much other than the fact that it is
twisty and turning and surprised us and
and
it really played on the assumptions that
we have for a series like this you know
there's all these assumptions that we
said with that as soon as she says it's
an ice planet that we just go of course
it would be but thinking about it
the earth is is desert and rainforest
why do they just assume it's an ice
planet but we did we played along we
went along with it
um i love that bit of an episode we see
some really good humor between o'neill
and um
sam we see the first hints of the will
they won't they relationship as they
become closer in lots of ways
this is the episode that we see sam
carter's character as
the genius but the caring soul the big
hearted person that she is really
starting to become developing instead of
that
militant feminist that we see in earlier
episodes
we really see sam's character develop
here and she starts she's this is the
episode for me where sam carter becomes
the sam carter we know and love we see
some really nice humor between daniel
jackson and teal at one point when he
realizes what's happened with the gay tv
student says what happens if you try to
ring your own telephone number and teal
goes ah and daniel's goes oh no i'm
asking the wrong person and then talk to
jenna hammond what happens when you
i just i i love that little bit and it's
something they play out a lot again in
the series and it's a recurring joke but
a brilliant one
it's my favorite episode
but to be honest it's my favorite
episode by about like that much because
there are so many brilliant episodes in
this first series episodes like cold
lazarus to be honest didn't do anything
for me didn't add anything to the series
but you know it's still good sci-fi
still it's still brilliant stargate i'll
still take over anything else i'm just
going to end by saying this series
series one was the foundation it's got a
few little lows in it because there's
there's a lot of information they've got
to give out in the first series there's
a lot of character development they've
got to do there's a got a lot of big
picture stuff they've got to do
and they did it really really well
they didn't rush it they took their time
they hinted at things they pulled away
from other things
they
underlined certain parts and they gave
us some amazing things to look forward
to
this series was the foundation
of
stargate
and oh my god what a foundation
a foundation that solidly built the next
10 years of sci-fi for me
went on to atlantis and even the sgu
and when stargate returns
which i am absolutely certain it will
i'm really hoping they don't brush away
all this great television and they
continue this amazing story
leave a comment tell me what you think
what is your favorite stargate episode
from the first series
also if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification hit all the like buttons
and share buttons and things that you we
all love to do and
you can actually join the channel help
me produce more content if you could do
that that would be great thank you very
much stay safe and i'll see you soon
[Music]